i'm not in a good mood
good this is what i want on tape silly
not smiling for once like the whole
world thinks she always is
at seven years old i always cast as
punky brewster
i remember was saved by the bell
director saying the minute you walk
under the stage you're no longer a child
anymore you're an adult
you miss me there were 12
kids in the business we all knew
everyone
we would talk for two three hours and
fall asleep on the phone
we were just so close i carried a camera
with me
everywhere i went we weren't concerned
about the internet we did
the things that teenagers did we just
happened to be in hollywood
hey what's up this is mark wahlberg
calling for some legs
because i'm kind of innocent to begin
with then it just
it got pretty crazy it was like our 60s
i started developing rapidly people are
calling me punky boobster
the last couple weeks have been weird
having guys pinch my ass you know
men treated me more like a woman and not
a 13 year old
this business i don't feel it's a place
for children you start getting in your
head
worrying about how you're perceived
friends were reaching out for help
it seemed like i was losing a friend
every week
this is really the first time i'm
watching the tapes back
now that i've opened pandora's box i
can't put any of this back
[Music]
the most awkward period in your life and
that's when we were in front of the
cameras
by you sharing these tapes you realize
you're not alone
i felt like i was alive when i was in
the rawness of it the amount of
love that was there
learning who i was and what life was
meant to be
that was with you i didn't know what
true self-love was
until this process began i can't believe
you have this
i don't know the ending i am absolutely
discovering it as we go
[Music]
the big question is what happens once i
unlock the ball
[Music]
bye